madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
que nous allons développer dans ce
journal en irlande du nord la marche
protestante s'est déroulée jusqu'à
présent dans le calme a porta donne le
défilé orangis haute sécurité sert de
tribune à ceux qui sont hostiles à tout
accord de paix en algérie le président
bouteflika annonce la grâce de plusieurs
milliers d'islamistes un air de liberté
avec tout à l'heure le concert de cheb
mami
il n'avait pas chanté depuis dix ans
dans son pays on peut lire excité
documents témoignages sur le passé
trotskiste de lionel jospin l'un des
acteurs de l'époque affirme que le
premier ministre dans les années 70 ça
fait partie de l'os il y un an un
militant à filtrer à l'intérieur du
parti socialiste et puis le mondial de
la pétanque plus de 10000 participants
un record pour ce sport qui est avant
tout une passion
je vous propose de commencer ce journal
avec l'histoire exemplaire du cycliste
américain lance armstrong après trois
ans d'absence et de soins intensifs pour
traiter son cancer celui qui fut l'un
des plus jeune champion de l'histoire a
endossé pour la première fois le maillot
jaune qu'il conserve aujourd'hui tout un
symbole pour ce jour de la fête de
l'indépendance aux états unis florent
gautreau philippe deslandes
il renaît un 4 juillet quel plus beau
symbole pour amstrong que ce maillot
jaune le jour anniversaire de
l'indépendance américaine
premier américain depuis greg lemond à
revêtir la tunique de leader armstrong
reste très réservé ce matin il n'a pas
dit un mot comme s'il voulait savourer
tout seul ce retour au plus haut niveau
lentz a pensé à tout ce qu'il a vécu moi
non j'étais juste heureux qu'il gagne
l'étape et le maillot jaune mais lens
c'est sûr il a dû repenser à tout ça
tout ça a commencé aux états unis il y a
trois ans lance armstrong a 25 ans il
annonce à la presse qu'il a un cancer
des testicules qui devient vite un
cancer généralisé
commence alors un combat a priori perdu
d'avancé contre la maladie
le texan est opéré de deux tumeurs au
cerveau quand nous l'avions rencontré en
97 il était amaigri et affaibli par la
chimiothérapie
mais sa volonté était impressionnante
armstrong a toujours gardé l'espoir de
remonter sur un vélo
il a vaincu son cancer il a recommencé
son métier jusqu'à cette victoire au
plus du coup un incroyable retour au
plus haut niveau et très populaire il a
vaincu son cancer
c'est une histoire émouvante et en plus
maintenant il remporte ce maillot jaune
dans nombreuses épreuves les plus
importantes au monde alors aux états
unis qu'on soit fan de vélo ou pas c'est
une histoire tout plaît beaucoup
une renaissance pour lens
une bénédiction pour les patrons du tour
qui dès ce matin ont axé leur
communication sur ce champion retrouvé
un enthousiasme un peu forcée qui ne
fait pas oublier les affaires récent du
passé si l'amérique a retrouvé un
champion le tour 99 se cherche toujours
une identité est la première étape du
tour de france qui s'est déroulé en
vendée le peloton après le départ sous
la pluie à montaigu pour une épreuve
longue de 208 km c'est le champion
d'estonie en titre jan kirsipuu qui a
dominé les autres sprinteurs devant le
belge tom steels et l'allemand erik
zabel
car si piou qui célébrera dans quelques
jours son 30e anniversaire
depuis le début de la saison c'est le
coureur qui a remporté le plus grand
nombre de succès et qu'elle était à
l'étranger avec en irlande du nord la
marche des orangistes un défilé sous
haute surveillance qui s'est déroulée
jusqu'à présent dans le calme la
manifestation protestante rassembler
apporta donne plus de 15000 personnes
on en attendait bien davantage le
cortège ne fait que s'approchait des
quartiers catholiques
une marche qui cette année prend un
relief particulier servant de tribune à
ceux qui sont hostiles à tout accord de
paix sur place
correspondant etienne leenhardt lorsque
les protestantes orangistes sont arrivés
en début d'après midi à l'entrée du
quartier catholique de portadown il
savait à quoi s'attend aux représentants
des forces de l'ordre qui les attendait
ils ont dit leur frustration de devoir
pour la deuxième année consécutive
renoncé à accomplir l'intégralité de
leur traditionnelle marche mais ils ont
aussi montré leur volonté de ne pas en
découdre et de tourner les talons sans
combattre les formats bien sûr que
certaines personnes auraient préféré des
formes d'action différentes mais nous
sommes les organisateurs de cette marche
et il est normal qu'ils se plient aux
règles que nous avons fixées à
d'éventuelles violences la police elle
s'était préparée plus de 1300 hommes
envoyés en renfort dans la province pour
le week end et le quartier catholique où
les habitants vivent ces marches comme
des provocations étaient totalement
quadrillé depuis plus d'un siècle les
protestants défilent ainsi chaque 4
juillet apporta d'armes pour commémorer
une ancienne victoire est démontré dans
une ville où il représente 80% de la
population qu'ils entendent rester
maîtres chez eux certains prenant même
des méthodes moins douces que les
organisateurs de la journée
malheureusement 30 années de violences
commises par les catholiques de l'ira
ont montré qu ici il n'ya que la
violence qui marche tandis qu'en fin
d'après midi certains voulaient déjà en
découdre d'autres s'employer à défendre
une irlande du nord résolument rattaché
au royaume uni tous très inquiet face à
un avenir qui si la paix s'installe un
jour dans la province passera forcément
par un partage du pouvoir avec les
catholiques
car s'il est bien un point sur lequel
tous les manifestants d'aujourd'hui font
preuve d'une belle unanimité c'est le
rejet pur et simple du nouveau plan
proposé cette semaine à belfast par tony
blair
quatorze mois après la signature des
accords du vendredi saint le processus
de paix en irlande du nord continue de
bégayer ou que ce vote de nouvelles
tensions entre la russie et le temps
après le refus de washington d'autoriser
le déploiement des troupes russes dans
la province la hongrie la roumanie et la
bulgarie
à la demande des américains ont fermé
leur espace aérien à l'origine de cette
décision un désaccord concernant le rôle
des troupes russes dans la kfor
parallèlement les premières troupes
turques qui font partie de la force de
paix sont arrivés en masse et douanières
pour atteindre le sud ouest du kosovo
elles seront stationnés à prizren
la population à fêter dignement en
milieu de journée l'arrivée de ces
militaires turcs une longue colonne a
traversé la ville
un événement puisque depuis plusieurs
siècles lecture qui à l'époque avait
occupé le kosovo n'avait pas remis les
pieds dans cette province
enfin toujours au kosovo la découverte
de nouveaux massacres les britanniques
ont exhumé les corps de sept enfants
kosovars et de cinq adultes qui avaient
été hâtivement réenterrés par les
villageois en algérie à la veille du 37e
anniversaire de l'indépendance le
président abdelaziz bouteflika a tenu
ses engagements et gracié comme il
l'avait promis il ya quelques jours des
milliers de prisonniers islamistes
un air de liberté souffle heures cette
journée sur alger avec dans quelques
heures le concert de cheb mami
depuis dix ans celui qui incarne la
jeunesse algérienne n'avait pas chanté
dans son pays
c'est un symbole récit éric meunier
lescamel ils sont donc au lundi qu est
lue à la télévision qui annoncé
aujourd'hui la libération et la grâce de
milliers de prisonniers islamistes
abdelaziz bouteflika le président
algérien n'aura pas attendu son discours
à la nation prévu demain pour
officialiser cette mesure une mesure qui
s'inscrit dans le processus dit de
concorde civile
en fait les négociations de paix avec
les mouvements islamistes
combien de prisonniers seront libérés
abassi madani le numéro un du fils
sera-t-il l'un d'eux l'état d'urgence en
vigueur sera-t-il levé pour savoir il
faudra patienter en attendant alger se
prépare à la fête
la trente septième fête de
l'indépendance algérienne est un
événement le retour du chanteur cheb
mami pour le premier grand concert de
raï depuis des années
et pour tous les efforts qu'ils
fournissent et que je trouve que c'est
un grand honneur pour eux de voir ici
aujourd'hui la cité à son chef mami
était déjà revenu dans son pays au rang
notamment mais jamais pour un grand
concert jamais dans la capitale on
apprend que la banque lui retourner le
concert de ce soir devrait attirer des
dizaines de milliers de spectateurs peut
être sombre alger derrière cheb mami
sera en fait cette nuit
une fête comme il en existe dans toutes
les capitales de la planète et la
violence toujours présentes en algérie
avec cet attentat sur une plage à 50 km
d'alger plusieurs personnes ont été
tuées hier après midi par une bombe qui
a explosé
l'engin était enfoui dans le sable et a
tué trois ou quatre personnes dont un
enfant
d'après les journaux algériens de ce
matin à bruxelles la manifestation de
milliers d'agriculteurs en colère et qui
protestent après la crise de la dioxine
dupeux dead que leur accordent les
autorités des incidents en fin de
cortège ligue b 6 1 une colère attisée
par la peur de voir leur métier mourir
les agriculteurs belges protestent
contre des aides qu'ils jugent
insuffisante depuis la crise de la
dioxine
ils étaient entre 4 et 5 milles dans les
rues de bruxelles aujourd'hui ces
agriculteurs interdits d'exportation
1400 élevages belges tous suspects sont
toujours bloqués
le ton est monté face à la police les
oeufs se sont écrasés en nombre sur les
forces de l'ordre et aussi sur certains
journalistes un véhicule d'une chaîne de
télévision
hamam été renversé plus d'un mois après
le déclenchement de la crise les
agriculteurs belges ont voulu démontrer
leur force
histoire de peser un peu plus dans les
décisions du futur gouvernement
en politique la fête des tricolores à
marignane avec la faillite annoncée du
parti de bruno mégret qui doit trouver
au plus vite 7 millions de francs en
effet le mouvement national front
national est resté en dessous du seuil
des 5% aux élections européennes du coup
ses dépenses de campagne ne seront pas
remboursés par l'état
bruno mégret réduit à organiser la quête
auprès de son électorat
michaël darmon guillaume faudra aller
bien bruno mégret veux bien payer
l'entrée de son propre meeting mais le
prix de la mise en scène est plafonnée
ce numéro retour à marignane sa ville
refuge en janvier dernier ici même bruno
mégret lancé le mouvement national dans
l'euphorie de la session aujourd'hui
avec 3,5 pour cent des voix aux
européennes l'atterrissage est rude
alors les militants viennent en aide
les petites enveloppes permettent d
autres nations nous n'avons pas de
problème politique pour assurer l'avenir
de notre mouvement les perspectives sont
devant nous par contre nous avons un
problème financier lié au fait que
l'état ne va pas rembourser nos comptes
de campagne c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'ai lancé une grande
souscription pour trouver les 7 millions
qui nous manque
7 millions ou la clé sous la porte chez
les mégrétistes la logique financière
impose pour l'instant sa loi beaucoup
d'adhérents et d'élus avaient prêté déjà
de l'argent pour financer la campagne
sans retour sur investissement j'étais
un peu déçu parce que je pensais qu'elle
a dépassé les 5%
j'étais très content pour lui très
satisfait à lloret de mar
il aurait bien dépasser le pen ça me
fait plaisir
pour le reste les mégrétistes rien ne
change
catherine mégret peaufine toujours son
rôle et pierre vial le chef de file des
païens tient son rang et son stand c'est
lui que jean marie le pen accuse de
racialisme tout est dans le vocabulaire
comme toujours
lui il dit racialiste nous nous
répondons identitaire sans ses cadres
nationaux en bout de table président du
mn signe son programme et persiste son
grand soir serait prévu pour 2020 les
élections municipales
en attendant les pauvres et chaussées
examine la demande de réintégration d'un
ingénieur polytechnicien
il a pour nom bruno mégret en corse très
organisations nationalistes ont décidé
hier et de façon solennelle de bannir
tous rapports violents entre ces
différentes mouvances
une façon de peut-être mettre un terme à
ces assassinats qui ont émaillé entre 93
et 96 les rangs nationalistes
les vétérans et diane richard hier
encore dans les années 95
ils s'entretuent est maintenant les 13
organisations nationalistes corses ont
décidé d'arrêter la violence entre eux
ils ont signé une charte un plus jamais
ça pour que l'union l'emportent sur la
division et les guerres intestines les
organisations du mouvement national
soussigné qu'elles affirment leur
position ou bien leur soutien à caen
destiny t1 s'engage sur l'année lé mans
et irrévocablement à bannir tous
rapports de force violents entre
nationaliste et ce en toutes
circonstances en revanche les
nationalistes ne sont toujours pas
d'accord entre eux pour décider l'arrêt
de l'action clandestine et de l'action
violente la cornée site et abordez vous
a vu que les personnes ont signé
qu'elles soient pour ou contre la candy
cité donc c'est un débat qui sera abordé
dans les discussions de il était
nécessaire au préalable de faire ce
protocole d'accord est de tomber
d'accord mais c'est un grand pas qu'on
vient de franchir la volonté des
organisations nationalistes d'avancer
ensemble sur la voie politique est
certes une nouveauté mais au même moment
le mât qui résonne encore de deux
conférences de presse clandestine celle
du flnc canal historique et celle d'un
nouveau mouvement clandestin l'armata
course politique encore avec ce document
qui semble mieux éclairer le passé
trotskiste de lionel jospin
depuis des années la rumeur voulait que
le premier ministre est appartenu dans
les années 70 l'eau c'est l'organisation
communiste internationale gérard leclerc
a retrouvé l'un des témoins clés de
cette époque il s'agit d'un ingénieur de
recherche à l'observatoire de meudon qui
affirme que lionel jospin a été un
militant infiltrés au parti socialiste
face à cette crise les partis 1974 les
français découvrent dans sa première
apparition télévisée un nouveau
responsable du ps lionel jospin
secrétaire à l'international adhérents
en octobre 1971 au lendemain du congrès
d'epinay au nouveau parti socialiste
il est tout de suite repéré par françois
mitterrand qui en quelques mois le
propulse dans le premier cercle des
dirigeants du parti
lionel jospin symbolise alors les sabres
à cette nouvelle génération de
socialistes formé au ps mais une rumeur
va bientôt courir selon laquelle
l'ancien fonctionnaire du quai d'orsay
aurait été un militant chevronné de
l'océan une organisation trotskyste
clandestine avant et même après son
adhésion au ps où ils auraient été
infiltrés
c'est ce qu'affirme aujourd'hui patrick
dié riche ingénieur de recherche en
astronomie qui a personnellement connu
lionel jospin dans une cellule
ses hits j'ai donc été affectés
vraisemblablement en septembre 71 à une
cellule de claire des sternes danse et
du clan des stages a les mêmes était la
responsable il y avait lionel jospin
j'ai donc rencontré cette occasion il
était lui y est d'ailleurs à ce moment
là le responsable de la structure au
dessus qui était le rayon ce qui fait
qu'on se voyait deux fois par semaine et
lui-même donc avait à se donner lui-même
s'appelait michel était le camarade
michel c'est sûr que c'était lui
oui il ya aucun doute lionel jospin
c'est quelqu'un qu'on n'oublie pas et
avait sa chevelure à la bob dylan l afro
froid américaine sans air très
distinguée il était toujours bien
habillé en sortait du milieu étudiant ou
les cheveux longs et tout ça allait
tenue un peu négligé dans n'oublie pas
lionel jospin quand on l'a rencontré
si on vous croit il l'aurait et en même
temps et et lci trotskiste et au parti
socialiste
je ne peux pas dire à cette époque là
qu'il était au parti socialiste je me
souviens de deux anecdotes
je sortais de la clandestinité j'avais
eu une intervention à l'observatoire de
meudon qui m'avait valu une réaction
extrêmement violent du parti communiste
français et on nous en avions discuté
avec lionel jospin et ce qui m'a dit
rester gravé dans ma mémoire
il m'a dit tu sais en raison du travail
clandestin que je fais je ne peux pas
t'aider
je ne peux pas venir même td et il a
même rajouté
bon ça peut être difficile pour toi mais
crois moi ce que je fais
si encore bien pire et j'ai même dû
éprouver la compassion à ce moment là
donc je savais qu'il faisait un travail
de clandestins je peux poser la question
de quel travail clandestin
je connaissais des dizaines de camarades
qui étaient qui aux crs qui à la cfdt
qui même dans le parti communiste
français et l' usage voulait et il aura
cette organisation sortie de la
clandestinité qu'on ne pose pas de
questions sur ce que faisait les parts
destin et puis un jour à la télévision
depuis dans la presse j'ai vu qu'en gros
responsable du parti socialiste je
croisais légale internationale
socialiste était mon camarade michel
c'est comme ça que j'ai découvert que
le camarade michel s'appelait lionel
jospin et qu'il était devenu un membre
influent du parti socialiste tant que je
le voyais et après doute de neige aux
pats a bien été un infiltré de l'eau
cieau parti socialiste a pour moi il n'y
a aucun doute là dessus puisque je les
ai connus comme militant de losséni me
disant qu'il faisait un travail de
clandestins je n'ai jamais entendu
quitter l'océan et je les revues dans ce
parti socialiste alors est ce que vous
êtes sûr que vous ne faites n'est pas
fait de confusion quand on les entend
pas lionel jospin dit on confond avec
mon frère qui lui était trop triste oui
c'est bon c'est son droit vers une chose
pareille mais il sait très bien que son
frère fait au moins 10 cm depuis ce que
lui n'a pas du tout du tout le même
aspect physique
en outre j'ai très bien connu son frère
à peu près à la même période pourquoi
parlez-vous aujourd'hui vous avez
quelque chose à me reprocher c'est quand
même pas scandaleux d'avoir été
trotskiste moi même je le dis je les ai
été jusqu'en 1987 le silence de sa part
et puis le silence de tous les militants
qui l'ont connu que la loi de l'omerta
règne dans une si bonne affaire aussi
ridicule nous paraît quelque chose qui
mérite qu'on le porte sur la place
publique
lionel jospin qui devient premier
secrétaire du ps en 1981 a reconnu avoir
eu des contacts avec des trotskistes
avant d'entrer au ps mais il a jusqu'à
présent toujours démenti avoir été
membre de l'osce et y est a fortiori
avoir été infiltré au parti socialiste
nous parlions hier de ce golden boy
britannique nick leeson emprisonné à
singapour pour avoir provoqué la
faillite de la banque barings
nick leeson qui est arrivé à londres
aujourd'hui il a reconnu ses fautes des
souhaite tourner la page qu'il a été
libéré pour bonne conduite et pour
raisons de santé puisqu'il souffre d'un
cancer
voilà qui nous amène aux états unis où
une nouvelle race de professionnels
profitent des fluctuations des marchés
boursiers pour réaliser des profits ou
des pertes substantielles en quelques
secondes ils se regroupent autour
d'ordinateurs rapide et performant on
les appelle les des traders se philippe
gassot à las vegas le chasseur de primes
se lèvent de bonne heure 'j'ai fait
partie de ces professionnels qui traque
les fluctuations de la bourse
les casinos de las vegas ça n'est pas
pour lui car les chances de gagner sont
trop minces
pas même une sur dix mais neuf chances
sur dix chez les des traders entraîner
cependant le métier est loin d'être à la
portée de tous il n'y a pas de place
pour l'émotion ici comme vous voyez
personne n'est réellement nerveux le
marché grimpe le marché allongez vous
devez être discipliné et peu motif que
ce n'est pas fait pour tout le monde
beaucoup de gens ne supportent pas parce
que c'est leur propre argent qui montent
et descendent le bois second parce qu'il
ne supporte pas une préfère avoir une
vie structurée
ceux qui ont accepté de déposer une
garantie de 25 mille dollars pour
rentrer dans la danse soit 150 mille
francs démarre la journée à la bourse de
new york
avec le décalage horaire il est depuis
6h30 l'exercice paraît simple il
consiste à choisir quelques sociétés
prometteuses en suivre les fluctuations
acheté à la baisse et vendre à la hausse
cela peut prendre quelques secondes
jamais plus de six minutes
une épreuve pour les nerfs mais quand on
est pro on ne manifeste aucune émotion
ou si peu lui a fait de mauvaises
affaires il a perdu beaucoup
jeff sentir encore une fois très bien
combien 7000 francs et hier à combien 9
me feront deux traders sur trois font de
l'argent mais lui bob gale toujours un
centime par connexion et il peut y en
avoir des centaines de milliers par jour
le développement de sa société prospère
il a maintenant des succursales en
floride dans le maryland et bien sûr
dont nevada anciens joueurs interdits
dans les casinos parce qu'il comptait
les cartes et gagnez trop il pèse
aujourd'hui 20 millions de dollars 120
millions de francs et ça n'est qu'un
début et il est certain d'être utile à
la société
les dettes readers sont le sens qu'ils
donnent vie au capitalisme il apporte
des liquidités sur le marché
c'est une profession lucrative pour ceux
qui ont la capacité de l'exercer avec
ses jeux les marchés risquent d'être
encore plus instable et imprévisible
mais c'est là dessus que vivent bien
d'ailleurs ceux qui ont les nerfs
solides qualités requises savoir dominer
son stress et ses émotions ils seraient
environ 5000 aux états unis et leur
nombre croît de 25 % par an en france
avec l'arrivée des premiers vacanciers
le nettoyage de certaines plages des
côtes bretonnes envahies par des algues
vertes elles sont inoffensives mais des
figures le bord de mer
ces algues sont liées à l'abondance de
nitrates générés par l'agriculture
intensive
jacques devaux gabriel kabir spectacle
de désolation comme chaque été la merde
rennes à la côte un cordon d'algues
vertes
et même si elles sont totalement
inoffensives elle n'incite pas à la
baignade
une catastrophe pour le responsable du
club des enfants
c'est un préjudice énorme pour moi tous
ces algues sur la sueur avant pas parce
que c'est glissant et ça n'incite pas
les parents à inscrire leurs enfants au
club à binic
les algues sont un sujet qui fâche le
maire ne souhaite plus en parler
l'an dernier pourtant ils manifestaient
pour dénoncer l'incurie des pouvoirs
publics
rompant ainsi une certaine loi du
silence on a voulu en parler pour que ça
s'arrête
qu'on arrête cette pollution c'est vrai
parce qu'il fallait le faire mais d'un
autre côté c'est vrai que ça nous a fait
du tort à une bonne publicité pour nick
reste les habitants qui ne cachent pas
leur colère h et révoltant il faut
prendre à l'heure actuelle des moyens
beaucoup plus importants que nos propres
pour cette régate avec des porcheries
pas de problème alors faute d'action
d'envergure de nombreuses communes du
littoral sont condamnés à nettoyer leurs
plaques véritable tonneau des danaïdes à
chaque mari ou presque les pelleteuses
entre en action
on peut en un été ramassé cinq mille
mètres cubes dalles des milliers de
francs de dépenses et pour que malgré
tout on puisse profiter de la plage
environnement et pollution avec
l'arrivée des grosses chaleurs les
risques de pollution à l'ozone sont à
nouveau à l'ordre du jour notamment dans
les grandes villes
vendredi le niveau deux de l' alerte a
été dépassé en ile de france et dans la
région lyonnaise hier hélène vergne
jacques gérard c'est l'été et tout
laisse penser qu'il fera beau et chaud
dans le même temps la qualité de l'air
que nous respirons va se détériorer
c'est ici airparif le dispositif de
surveillance pour l'ile-de-france que l'
alerte à la pollution sera donné
plusieurs fois par jour ils sont
répertoriés et analyser les polluants
atmosphériques
au hit-parade le dioxyde d'azoté
d'origine automobile et l'ozone
on a fait deux types de populations
différentes qui sont concernés par deux
pollutions différentes sur la zone
centrale de l'agglomération les
franciliens sont exposés en particulier
un francilien sur ou deux et exposés à
des niveaux de dioxyde d'azoté qui
excède l'objectif de qualité
par contre en zone rurale ce sont là les
franciliens qui sont exposés à des
dépassement de l'objectif de qualité
pour l'ozone la pollution atmosphérique
n'épargne donc personne l'été en période
d'anticyclone les vents transportent les
polluants de la ville les oxydes d azote
dans les zones rurales là sous l'effet
de la chaleur et du rayonnement solaire
se forment l'ozone l'ozone qui accentue
les crises d'asthme chez les personnes
les plus fragiles notamment les enfants
dire que la pollution intervient chez
ces enfants exploités pour 30 à 60%
qu'est ce que ça veut dire dire que
quand on a des fluctuations des
modifications de la pollution de tous
les jours en dehors des pics mais il ya
30 à 60% des enfants asthmatiques qui
ont des symptômes qu'il n'aurait pas dû
avoir à cause de la pollution plastique
dont cinq ont des normes plus strictes
de registre automobile laisse espérer
une baisse sensible de la pollution
d'ici là il faudra patienter
puis on apprend à l'instant que
plusieurs centaines d'hectares sont
parcourus par un incendie dans les alpes
de haute provence
d'importants moyens ont été engagés près
de 200 pompiers des canadair et un
hélicoptère sont donc à pied d'oeuvre
pour cette journée de dimanche où se
poursuivre sans vraie difficulté les
départs en vacances fabrice o c'est
valérie criton on suit le travail d'une
société de dépannage sur l'autoroute à
10 dans l'essonne bon bah ça commence
bien
alors je leur ai prouvé un dépanneur en
quête d'une voiture en panne première
mission pour robert trouver une renonce
elle n'est pas à l'endroit indiqué par
la gendarmerie alors il parcourt
l'autoroute et scrute les bandes d'arrêt
d'urgence
à peine cinq minutes de recherche robert
a repéré son premier client de la
journée cet homme a calé sur l'autoroute
le moteur refuse de redémarrer mais
impossible de réparer sur place
il faut transporter la voiture au garage
le plus proche on me dépanne c'est celle
pop c'est bien
coût d'un dépannage durant le week-end
près de 500 francs robert lui doit
repartir
chaque jour il couvre un tronçon de 130
km d'autoroutes 130 km où tout peut
arriver surtout lors des jours de grands
départs sont centrale vient de l'appeler
il doit se rendre sur les lieux d'un
accident
une mission prioritaire pour tous les
dépanneurs et à chaque fois il faut
s'attendre au pire
maintenant les enfants chez quick ans
un grand cas des enfants
bernard oui c'est pour nous
oui la conduite de chacun sait plus
comment cet homme
sexy g ou jamais
pour des fois c'est au mont bleu vivra
son rêve
or des coûts
attends vacants
95 cents écoles à la rentrée
en dix minutes robert arrive sur les
lieux de l'accident une collision qui
n'a pas fait de blessé
remplaçons voiture il y mène sa cent
places font si peur pour mes enfants
ils sont en bonne facture
les appels se succèdent toute la journée
un rythme épuisant pour un salaire de 13
mille francs par mois robert doit à
présent préparer une roue crevée
un exercice particulièrement dangereux
sur le bord de l'autoroute
voyez ce coffret j'ai une voiture arrive
elle peut cacher être sûrs tels que l'on
apprécié pour pas être fauché mais
robert est loin d'avoir achevé sa
journée ce soir encore il sera de
permanence les vacances c'est pour
septembre
probert partir en vendée par l'autoroute
bien sûr en tournée dans les ports de la
manche le dernier terre-neuvas français
il s'agit d'un de ces bateaux utilisés
au début du siècle pour pêcher la morue
au large de terre-neuve le marité c'est
son nom est aujourd'hui à vendre à
nemours gay patrie sur storm ont
embarqué à bord
je suis très fier de ce bateau chaque
pièce on a construit de nos mains on a
coupé les arbres de la forêt ça marche
et pourtant le marité est aujourd'hui à
vendre dernier terre-neuvas français le
bateau a été construit au début du
siècle pour pêcher la morue dans les
eaux glacées de terre-neuve richard l'a
retrouvé abandonné sur une île au large
de l'ecosse la première fois que j'ai vu
ça m'a fait comme un choc
c'était une épave une ruine tout était
pourri ça sentait mauvais mais on s'est
dit on va pas s'arrêter là pendant dix
ans avec quelques amis il reconstruit le
marité cent mille heures de travail basé
en suède
le trois-mâts sert maintenant de
charters pour les touristes de frida
kahlo pour ce bateau c'est la liberté
regarde autour de toi tu as le monde
l'homme
si tu veux aller en belgique au canada
en australie choisi ya pas de limite
et pourtant sa liberté
richard a choisi d'y renoncer après 12
ans de navigation
il rêve d'horizons plus calme d'une
petite maison en suède d'enfants alors
il a décidé de se séparer du marité pour
12 millions de francs il aimerait juste
que son bateau trouvent acquéreur en
france qu'il retrouve son berceau se
serrent le jeu pourrait le vendre à une
émirs du golfe
lorsqu'elles ont joué ils seront durs
mais non il est temps que le marité
reviennent chez lui puis en france
à marseille l'événement est de taille
avec le mondial de la pétanque plus de
dix mille joueurs sont inscrits un
record
les deux tiers des départements français
sont représentés pour ce loisir qui est
aussi un sport et surtout une passion
karine comazzi françoise maison un
mondial de la pétanque à marseille c'est
forcément une histoire de famille chez
nous c'est mon pauvre père mes frères
si le veut mes soeurs monde fille mon
mari on est tous accros voir plus de dix
mille trois cents participants répartis
sur une vingtaine de sites dans les
allées sablonneuses du parc borély règne
la passion la concentration et un zeste
de mauvaise fois depuis dix ans
marguerite arbitre le mondial de la
pétanque appeler en cas de litige c'est
mesure à elle ne souffre aucune
contestation
aux familles 60 10 fois plus dur que
soucier de l'hebdo minuit vous savez
qu'un homme aime être dominés donc à
partir de là vous en faites sûrement les
mêmes inculque à ses pairs d'un autre
âge je suis revenu tout ça pas les
perdre
au cours de cette première journée 1700
équipes ont été éliminées
mais ce n'est que dans trois jours qu'on
connaîtra les champions seuil est
champion du monde
wimbledon c'est pete sampras numéro un
mondial qui a remporté les
internationaux de tennis face à agassi
il détient désormais le record toutes
catégories de deux des victoires dans un
grand chelem chez les dames c'est aussi
une américaine lindsay davenport qui
célébra sa façon la fête nationale
américaine en battant steffi graf 6 4 7
christophe du chien c'est rien de le
dire mais pete sampras est vraiment un
type au poil
pour la sixième fois de sa carrière il
remporte un titre à wimbledon et sa
jusqu'à aujourd'hui personne ne l'avait
fait par la même occasion il gagne son
12e titre dans un tournoi du grand
chelem seul l'australien roy emerson a
fait aussi bien
bref hormis roland garros sampras a tout
gagné et cet après midi là même gagner
beaucoup
quatre millions et demi de francs en ce
jour de fête nationale aux états unis
sampras a largement dominé son
compatriote andre agassi
sampras qui possède tout l'art du tennis
sur gazon et qui va s'imposer en moins
de deux heures et trois sets 6-3 6-4 7-5
sampras qui avec 17 aces réussis avait
sorti son service du dimanche
il dira un peu plus tard qu'il a disputé
le meilleur match de sa carrière
aujourd'hui c'était donc sampras et sans
reproche
chez les dames qui jouait un dimanche à
cause de la pluie qui est tombée à
londres toute la semaine l'américaine
lindsay davenport s'est imposé sans
grandes frayeurs
cette demoiselle qui mesure 1 m 89 a
battu steffi graf de toute sa puissance
en deux sets 6 4 7 5
âgé de 23 ans elle gagne son deuxième
tournoi du grand chelem
quant à steffi graf déçu elle a annoncé
qu'elle avait disputé cet après midi le
dernier wimbledon de sa carrière
après la gay pride à paris la semaine
passée sa cologne en allemagne que se
déroulait aujourd'hui cette fête de la
communauté homosexuelle
un cortège de plus de 100 char et 600000
personnes venus de toute l'allemagne et
des pays voisins pour participer à cette
fête le ministre écologique lieu jusqu'à
6 heures était sur un char aux couleurs
de son parti
c'est la fin de ce journal je vous
rappelle les principaux titres en
irlande du nord la marche protestante
s'est déroulée jusqu'à présent dans le
calme a porta donne le défilés
orangistes sous haute sécurité serve de
tribune à ceux qui sont hostiles à tout
accord de paix en algérie le président
bouteflika annonce la grâce de plusieurs
milliers d'islamistes
un air de liberté avec tout à l'heure le
concert de cheb mami il n'avait pas
chanté depuis dix ans dans son pays
dans un instant de la météo nathalie
rihouet 20h50 votre film l'étudiant
étranger 23h55
le dernier journal elle mettait demain à
7h50 dans les 4 vérités françoise
laborde recevra le président de la cnam
à 20h vous retrouverez claude sérillon
je vous remercie de votre attention
excellente fin de soirée sur france 2